[Music]
you posted your you were diagnosed with
breast cancer and your first day of
chemo and you spoke to the shock that
you felt and we felt it too how are you
coping
coping i'm coping well the last march i
just turned 70 and i thought i'm
invincible i'm powerful i'm you know
healthy and then like
a month or two later and i get this
crazy news it was really um just you
know sort of knocked the wind out of my
sails so lucky that we're living in this
day and age when breast cancer is as i
said not only treatable but curable i
have you know every conviction that's uh
i too will uh get through it i've got
this you got this yes
do you see life in a different light now
everyone says that this is a journey
that changes you forever
the day i got that call
my doctor to tell me that i had cancer
oh yeah i started realizing how much i
loved life and the thought like
you mean i i might not live to to see
another summer i mean i might not live
just to see this project come to
fruition or you know i make up
that was so horrifying for me i was you
know in a pretty dark place but you just
gotta
pull on all your resources and you know
just get yourself out of there i am a
survivor and i'm just gonna you know
give it my all and not even think of it
as so much of a battle but think of it
as a healing
experience
and
embracing all of it and so far
so good